hello everyone and welcome back to binge
battle i'm just your host merely mark
ellis this is i believe our first
episode of the year and what a way to
kick it off we're talking about sex and
the city i have a long and storied
history with sex in the city because you
see when the movie came out i was
already familiar with the show when the
show came out on hbo it was sort of
something that all of me and my boys
wanted to watch too just to get a
glimpse as to what the opposite sex is
thinking now i was in school so i really
had no need to or means to apply any of
that knowledge anywhere i really still
don't but it's nice to know and i enjoy
the adventures of the fearsome foursome
throughout their run at least tv show in
the first movie the second movie uh
we'll talk about that probably hopefully
not during this show because this is
binge battle we are focusing on the tv
show sex and the city welcome back
everyone and now to introduce our
esteemed guests today they're both big
fans of sex in the city as you can
imagine
starting first with a returning favorite
you know her as the host of live at the
roxy which is still running daily my
goodness she is also one of the
co-creators of the world girls hit
program
miss roxy stryer is back roxy hello
welcome back i've been waiting for this
moment for a very long time mark a very
long time probably longer than people
waited for a revival of the series
okay so you've been dreaming about this
moment and the first time that became a
sugar plum in your head when was the
first time that you stumbled upon sex in
the city was it airing was that were you
did the movie get you in what was your
entry point it was definitely something
that the older girls were watching
and i wanted to be one of the older
girls and i had those parents who were
like watch anything you want we don't
care what you're doing with your life so
i did and learned a lot about both sex
and the city
and which i just emphasize the and
because the amount of people who still
call this sex in the city
it's just egregious pay it some respect
it's both sex and it's also the city so
i've been watching this forever and then
i did a re-watch and then i'm a big
movie watcher and i will fight
to the death about how great the movies
are as well
so i i i might have a little bit of a
blind spot when it comes to the show
because to me it's it's like my family
it's like my friends it's how i learned
to be a woman so now we introduce a
newcomer to binge battle but you're
probably already familiar with her great
work everything from comedy to hosting
tv to getting in the world of politics
you've seen her on everything from
huffington post to ew writing
contributing hosting the whole gamut and
now here on binge battle it is heather
gardner hello heather how are you hello
oh my gosh you make me sound so official
i'm doing great and i'm so excited to be
here yeah y'all both have like the best
backgrounds in the showbiz right now
because we've all been practiced at this
for the last couple years so heather i'm
gonna ask you the same question i asked
roxy when was the first time that you
came upon
sex in the city was it something that
you initially glommed onto or were you
resistant i was never resistant but i
did not have cool parents unlike roxy
did who just let me watch anything i
wanted at 10 years old i don't even
think we had an hbo subscription i think
we were pretty much basic cable at that
point too so my first time watching sex
in the city was
in my late 20s i was already married and
immediately regretted not spending my
my 20s having sex all over a big
fabulous city
well i mean yeah it is it's sex and the
city there is a lot of sex in this city
and i've always said it right roxy for
the record but
anytime a show is called what it's got
that and symbol in there i tend to my my
southerness comes out and i just go sex
and the city y'all but today it is sex
and the city and it's between heather
gardner and roxy stryer here's how it
works we have four rounds unless there's
a tie breaker then we'll go to a fifth
round in each round each of our
competitors gets a minute opening
statement about whatever question i pose
and then they'll have a 30 second
rebuttal period and then there will be a
final argument that's just going to be a
quick statement could be 10 to 15
seconds could be less if you want it to
be it's your call it is sex and the city
and i am so excited to get this episode
underway and so we are going to start
with the question of best character that
is our first topic here today and to
kick us off it's going to be heather
gardner heather whenever you're ready
you may begin your opening statement for
the best character on sex and the city
well i had to grab my cosmopolitan
martini because do you prefer your
martini straight up or with a twist
samantha hands down every day i will
fight anybody who says otherwise and the
reason why i love samantha so much is
because you know everybody goes through
their journey through the six seasons of
the show but samantha from day one she's
so comfortable with herself she's so
comfortable with her sexuality it's sex
and the city after all she's so
comfortable with her body and i feel
like she's the inspiration for all the
other girls and kind of you know we
don't know how old she is she just keeps
that to us but she is like that older
sister for these other girls and i
absolutely just cannot get over her
confidence my favorite favorite moment
of the entire series for her is when she
decides that she is going to take nude
photos
not for a man not for playboy not for
her girls but for herself to look at her
ass and say
i am amazing what i love you but i love
me more samantha i will drink to you all
day every day i can do the cosmos i
don't think anybody needs naked pictures
of me even just myself so let's go over
to roxy so roxy
heather took samantha who is your best
character on sex in the city i think for
the first time in binge battle history
i can't do anything other than also take
samantha but for different reasons
because here's the thing you can't ask a
sex and the city fan who their favorite
character is who the best character is
and have them not say samantha because
you would have to be
you not a fan you'd have to be not a fan
of the show that's the truth so i'm
going to tell you guys a story i have a
little a story that i want to tell you
guys this is a hat i received in the
mail about five years ago from one of my
closest friends from when we were in
high school and we watched the show
together she sent me a hat that says i'm
an effing miranda like i'm a miranda
i haven't spoken to this girl since this
hat came into my mail to call somebody
anything other than a samantha is to say
you are a whiny bratty annoying bad
friend samantha's the only one on the
show who is a legitimately good friend
who chooses not just
her friends over men every single day
but she's also the first time we've ever
seen a character on television and i
mean ever who is having sex with whoever
she wants consensually and feels 100
great about it we have never seen that
before we had seen people sleep around
and all of their friends were really
rude about it and then they feel really
ashamed about it the next day but she
was the first one to be like what are
you talking about i can do what i want
here she never judged her friends for
anything else they judged her back but
she was the best friend and the best
character on the show hands down okay so
these are great points y'all are making
and you did pick the same character
that's fine i love when we make history
we have hats we have cosmos so heather
i'm gonna go back to you for your
rebuttal first you don't necessarily
have to go against roxy because that
would be attacking your own choice as
well but you can just continue to make
the argument and i'll just have a really
tough time judging this round well like
i said before too is like i saw the
series well after i was married so i
mean obviously they don't have great sex
but it's i don't live that life and i
really like latched on to miranda excuse
me oh wow i'm sorry samantha i latched
onto her
i just got roxy got me in my head
because no you never want to be called
miranda no no no um you know and other
people called me a charlotte and
yeah i am charlotte but i always aspired
to be the samantha i wanted to be that
person who could just feel
so so comfortable with anything and
talking about anything she says what is
ever on her mind she walks up to people
and says calls them up
for
hurting her friend she's the fiercest
friend of all of them and roxy was right
she never let a man get in the way of
her friendship and honestly that's what
this whole show is about yes it's sex
and the city but it's really about your
girlfriend and living in a fabulous city
and she just encapsulates all of that
for me
okay so roxy it seems like heather
enjoys somewhat living vicariously
through a character like this man what
can i say what can i say
uh your feelings roxy for your rebuttal
well as i am still very alone and not
married and single i get to live the
samantha lifestyle so i she's near and
dear in my heart because she is somebody
who encouraged me to live my best life
and to go out there and do what i want
but to get into some specifics not only
did she not just choose men over herself
over her friends she chose herself over
men she's one of the only people on the
show when she falls in love with richard
she says i love you richard but i love
me more and she decides that she cannot
be with him we don't see any other woman
on this show do that and it's saying to
all the women out there it is better to
be alone than to be with the wrong
person and
that's not something that any of the
other characters on the show ever made a
decision about she also did something
that we hadn't seen on television before
too which is that when miranda decides
she thinks she wants an abortion she's
the friend that supports her and we
hadn't seen that because charlotte gives
her a really hard time in his and and uh
was in her own thoughts about her own
situation and carrie is just has her
head so far up her butt sometimes that i
don't even think she's listening to the
conversation half the time plus you know
she's the best character on the show
because people won't even watch the new
show because she's not on it any other
character that was not there people
would be watching but no
people aren't watching the show because
they're like no samantha i'm out
uh it's really a uh uh too bad about
charlotte i always considered myself a
charlotte kind of fella but y'all are
winning me over to the samantha argument
so let's go to your closing statement
starting with you heather if you could
sum up in a tiny capsule why you love
samantha so much
i mean fierce fabulous just unashamedly
herself and i love i i'm gonna have to
disagree with roxy here too she puts
herself first and i think for women it
is so so so important and the fact that
we got that in the late 90s and i mean
honestly all throughout history now
thank you television we have that role
model and i'm gonna look up to her
literally for the day i die
okay roxy your final statement
supporting samantha
she's a character that's not just the
best character on the show but one of
the best characters we've ever seen in
tv history
ever to the point where on binge battle
we both had to fight for her
i think that without samantha there
wouldn't have been this new wave of sex
positivity in women on television
because hbo tested it they said oh if we
do this are people going to be okay with
this or are they going to hate her
character and they showed that not only
did people accept her character they
loved her the most and that gave other
shows in the future permission to have
samantha's on their shows it's a lot to
chew on here but first and foremost i
just want any presidential candidate
watching this program to realize hey
look we just had a nice debate but they
agree about a topic and a fly didn't
land on either one of their heads so
maybe we don't have to be young and
screaming at each other at all times
maybe we can actually agree on some
issues now if that issue is samantha and
supporting samantha i think that you're
gonna look back on this show and say it
just continue to realize how important
this show was in breaking new ground on
television and how it's a mirror to
society and so if you have samantha the
thing that impresses me about both
y'all's arguments is that you said some
of the same things but you also looked
at her differently because roxy like you
said you're single heather you said
you're married but i it seems like the
grass is greener for both y'all on the
other side sometimes but if we're just
judging it i would always assume that
somebody who is single who's young and
watching this show says oh i i'm like a
samantha i want to be like a samantha
but i was i was really impressed to hear
how much samantha had won over heather
who had already been married before she
had ever seen the show and glommed on to
samantha so i think i'm leaning slightly
toward the cosmo helps too i i think i'm
slightly leaning towards heather here in
round one so a great argument by both
y'all roxy i want you to keep the hat
ditch the friendship but keep the hat
but the point goes to heather in round
one so heather is on the board it is one
to nothing but we have a whole lot of
binge battle left as we careen into
topic number two and this show ran for a
long long time on hbo and now i'm gonna
have the fun task of asking these two
incredible personalities to break down
their favorite moment of all the seasons
what was your one favorite moment roxy
you get to kick this round off with your
opening statement your favorite moment
from sex and the city
this is the moment that encompasses the
entire show the most so if you love this
show i don't see how it's possible that
this isn't the standout moment to you
there is an episode season four episode
one it's called agony of the ecstasy uh
i like a little pun here it's e x like x
to see you know
okay it's funny you'll laugh when you
get there you know this episode is all
about
carrie
turning 35 which as a woman who is
single in my 30s it's a very stressful
situation to be having birthdays in your
30s to be wondering if you're ever going
to find your man to to know that this
might be my life forever it might not be
my life forever when i come home it's
just me what is it that i do have and
it's a grueling episode honestly where
you're watching her go through a lot of
different things she throws herself a
birthday party dinner everybody's
running late she's sitting there alone
for hours it doesn't work out no one
shows up but at the end of the episode
she's gone home to shower she's taking
off her makeup she's listening to her
voice machines every single friend is
leaving her a voice message saying i'm
sorry i'm in traffic i'm late i couldn't
be there and then she's in the shower
her friends come busting through her
door charlotte comes and gets her and
says we are so sorry we're late we're
taking you out they're sitting
downstairs uh at a restaurant they're
sitting there the four of them and she
opens up and kerry says i don't know
that i'm gonna be okay i i hate to say
it out loud and it's not always about a
man but am i gonna be alone and they
decide the four of them
you know what
your soul mate isn't a guy all of our
soul mates are each other
and guys are just the people we have fun
with
and that is the whole theory of this
entire show is that these four women
whether i understand it or not because
sometimes their friendship is not i
don't understand but they have their
soulmates the four of them are soulmates
they're supposed to be together and the
guys that come through the show really
aren't the point and it's this beautiful
moment and a pact they all agree on and
that's what the entire well that is what
sex in the city is all about
as a guy i probably should be
disagreeing with you but i agree that we
should just be background in y'all's
lives as long as we get to watch
football on sundays i'm fine with that
arrangement let's go to heather now
because that's a really poignant moment
in the history sex of the city and it
really typifies not not necessarily
where the show started but where the
show had
gotten to by that point so it had this
beginning entryway and then you have
this matriculation to these folks
realizing that they really do care about
each other the most and they are an
insular unit so heather it's a tall
order what is your favorite moment from
all of sex in the city
i'm not gonna disagree with roxy that
that was a beautiful moment i may or may
not have teared up when i re-watched it
you know in preparation for this okay
let's just get out of the way but for me
but the whole purpose of this show and
especially like when hbo put this out
because roxy everything you said about
like how this is a pop culture
phenomenon and flip the script on women
and these strong single women in their
30s exploring the sexuality i believe
that 100
and to me it all comes to at a head here
with episode nine of season six a
woman's right to shoes because this
theme plays out the entire series that a
woman's place is not to be sex positive
not to be out and about gallivanting in
your 30s you need to lock down a man you
need to have your kids you need to have
your friends or whatever but those are
the most important things not you just
living your life and we saw that in
season one she goes to a baby shower and
she has all these internal thoughts like
am i going to be this person what what
do i want for my life well flash forward
six years later she goes to another baby
shower her
manolos get stolen from the baby shower
and she asked her friends she's like hey
can you pay for these shoes and her
friend's like i am not here to pay for
your extravagant life these are your
choices i have a real life i have real
responsibilities as a wife and a mother
and she shoe shamed her but not i mean
not just her clothes but really honestly
it was her lifestyle
i'm sorry that you don't have a real
life like the rest of us women here and
in season one carrie walked away and and
you know never really thought about it
again but in season six she went back
she called her friend and was like no i
am marrying myself he i have registered
at manolo blahnik and you are going to
pay for my shoes and she got her shoes
and i just thought it was such a
beautiful beautiful moment and it is
like the full circle of the entire
series is like women can be whatever
they want to be and that's the whole
point of the show to me you get to make
your own choices as a woman not what
society says not what any man says
certainly what you say is right for you
amen and if i ever meet a young lady who
would prioritize shoes over kids um
just tell me where you want the ring
all right let's go back to roxy streier
for her rebuttal why is your episode
moment maybe better than the shoe
incident so here's what i'm not going to
do mark i am not going to sit here and
say that shoe thing was not amazing it
is legendary for for all of us single
women out here who have decided to have
a different kind of lifestyle who have
had to go to 8 000 baby showers and have
people judge us for everything we do
that shoe moment was the ultimate shoe
revenge and you're just rooting for
every single second of kerry's journey
it's amazing but it's scary and it's
just carrie
and there's no samantha and there's no
miranda and there's no charlotte and
although arguably carrie is the
protagonist of this show this show is
about four best friends and this moment
is about one girl in her shoes and yes
it is showing that one girl and yes it
is awesome that after she asked her
friend to write a check and the girl
tried to write a 200 check which is
clearly not how much those shoes cost
him we all know that i'm looking at
every one of you out there
after all of that
it's just carrie's show that's the
carrie show and it's not the best moment
of sex in the city
feels like those are the air jordans for
uh i think i'm starting to feel what how
she felt when she lost the shoe so let's
go back to heather heather um it is just
about carrie but it is a very important
moment to you elaborate
well it's important to me because yes
even though i am married i go to plenty
of baby showers where they're like okay
you're married where's the kids like
come on come on i really resonated with
you know i'm i'm married but i don't
have kids no but i mean yes it was
carrie's like singular moment but like
she does have conversations about that
moment with every single one of those
characters in that episode and charlotte
really pushes back and she's like oh my
wife you're like you know we we want to
celebrate all these good times in my
life and she's like no we need to
celebrate everything not just the
marriage not just the kids and charlotte
didn't agree with her and carrie uh you
know why she didn't argue she was like
that's what you want for you but it's
not what i want for me and then she had
the same conversation with miranda and
then samantha and they all disagree i
think that's the whole point of the show
is like whatever you choose whatever it
is and maybe i mean that's great that
they're all together and that is the
beauty of the show that they can all
come together and be each other's soul
mates but they're all still their own
separate people at the same time lifting
each other up and supporting each other
and being there for the hard times being
for the great times whatever that looks
like for each individual woman's life
great time definitely had a baby shower
for this guy so let's go back to roxy
for your final statement here this is
clearly moments that you are both very
passionate about so roxy your closing
argument it's a question we've all asked
ourselves at some point no matter what
phase in life you're in is what is a
soul mate and am i is my husband my soul
mate is my
is uh a friend my soul mate it does a
soulmate even exist and for this show to
take this moment to redefine that your
soulmate does not have to be the person
that you go to sleep and wake up with it
doesn't have to be even the father of
your children the mother of your
children or whatever it is it can be
whatever you want and we are possibly as
a society putting the significance on
the wrong thing and so to give the
option to people the first time that we
are seeing the option you your soulmate
might already be in your life and it
might just be your best friend and
that's going to be the person who's
there from beginning to end
what a beautiful moment for for anybody
who's ever been confused about that word
powerful stuff my soul mate is uh
snoring right over there in the corner
all right heather your final statement
for round two it's been a good one
oh it's hard because i agree with
everything that roxy is saying but at
the end of the day like yes you have
your soul mate and like i can
confidently say that i have found my
soul mate in my man but at the same time
like if he were to
knock on all the wood go away for
whatever reason like i have to be
comfortable with myself and my choices
and your soul mate another person if you
rely on yourself for another as to be a
part of another person i feel like
you're setting yourself up for failure
the moment you decide that you are the
most important person in your life
that's when i think you're winning and
that was that moment to me and that's
the magic of this show and and the
beauty of these two debates that we just
had is that if you're just looking at
this from a scoreboard perspective you
would say soul mates versus shoes that's
an easy win for soul mates but the shoes
represent something they represent a
lifestyle they represent how one wants
to conduct their own business and one
being happy with that lifestyle choice
versus what the conventions of society
say the the soulmates becoming that and
and showing up for you in your most
desperate hour it's certainly not the
birthday i would want because i remember
that episode roxy and
in my opinion carrie's having the best
birthday of all time because she's by
herself she has to go have dinner alone
nobody's bothering her and then her
friend show up and drag her out but i
understand where she is in that moment
and so sex and the city is a show that
began with the opening credits and it
was kerry and it was her story but as we
matriculated through the seasons we
realized that they really do complement
each other so well and so as much as it
is carrie's tale to tell for the most
part we also do not have a show if we do
not have this foursome that is always
going to have each other's backs and i
don't think it's ever been better
exemplified in that episode that was
carrie's birthday so by a slimmer margin
than you might expect i am going with
roxy's decision here and it is a
one-to-one ball game we are tied after
two rounds as we head into round number
three the best season this show ran for
a number of celebrated seasons got super
high ratings buffo box office
and now we have to boil it down to the
best season so we're gonna start with
you heather what is the best season in
the history of sex and the city season
three to me was the best uh season in
the history of sex in the city one
because it's finally like we get over
the shock of just women being sexual i
think it took a couple years for society
to get to that point and it was very um
the first two seasons were very much
focused on a lot of relationship fails
and the shock and horror of dating in a
city in your 30s and these hilarious
sometimes really gross like moments and
being with your friends but by season
three we really start to like we've got
to know the characters and they start to
grow and it doesn't just become about
each episode isn't just about their own
individual experiences it's about like
how the these are shaping them as a
person and i think everybody grows
charlotte to me grows the exact the most
because she gets exactly what she wants
by the end of it the first two seasons
she was looking for the love of her life
and she had all these boxes she needed
to check off he needed to come from a
good family needed to come from a good
school needed to be rich obviously she
got everything she wanted but by the end
of it she realized that just because you
checked all the boxes doesn't
necessarily mean that you're going to be
happy and she was missing the intimacy
and then you know as the seasons go on
she grows to find that uh samantha grows
too because yes she's fabulous less
she's fierce but she was also really
shallow
in the first few seasons too and she
opens herself up to even more
experiences by not worrying about the
richest guy or the most handsome guy um
you know but she's to me the click the
clicking moment was when she started
dating the shorter guy and realized that
like she likes someone who can make her
laugh there too and miranda i mean i
think she's like the pessimist of the
show and that's when she meets steve and
that's when she realizes that oh
wait i am allowed to have nice things
and let steve come in and obviously
there's like ebbs and flow as we go
throughout the rest of the season or the
rest of the series but that to me was
just like their moments of just
flourishing and really getting in to
their own selves to just grow and that's
that's honestly what i love about shows
in general is like i need to see these
characters grow and grow and grow they
can't just keep making these same
mistakes over and over and i think
season three really was that for me wait
are you saying that you need to give a
tv show more than a season to really let
it show it's true that's i mean
shocking shocking i know
are you listening to heather tv execs
give it a shot all right roxy your
favorite season your opponent
technically took season three are you
going deeper into the show or are you
going with one of the first two um i
noticed that you left out a lot of
carrie storyline in season three i'm
well looking forward to see what you do
when you get to that let's talk a little
bit about my favorite season season six
to be fair equally as polarizing this is
some people's favorite season this is
some people's not favorite season
because it's the longest season we've
got a lot to chew on here and that means
of course there are going to be some
episodes that aren't as powerful but
overall i would take a meh episode of
sex in the city and
15 great ones and five meh ones than any
other eight episode season where it
comes and goes and at least you didn't
pick season one and they're talking
directly to the camera and it's like the
atrocities we've lived with these people
for six
seasons these are characters now that we
love in our souls they're extremely
flawed but we know them and so in this
season it's the first time that we
decide okay this is a comedy but this is
real what are we gonna do what happens
to real people in real life and uh we we
are dealing with cancer this season
we're dealing with people um getting
married we're dealing with people
getting heartbroken in a way that we
hadn't seen before and deciding whether
or not you should go for a guy who might
make you feel everything you want in
your soul but at the end of the day is
the wrong person for you um the samantha
breast cancer storyline is one of the
best story lines we did on the show it
results in one of the best scenes that
i've ever seen on television when the
when her boyfriend decides to shave his
head and just takes the clippers and
shave it everybody felt for her so much
in those moments charlotte converting to
being jewish thank you to having any
kind of jews on television so people
understand even what it means to be
jewish and actually getting her involved
in this uh
the guy before the guy we have carrie
with alexander petrovsky which is the
only reason that we're okay with her
ending up with big because we're like oh
she's tried everything else okay it's
gotta be big fine she's she's done
everything else there's nothing else
more that we can do this is what has to
happen here so for all those reasons and
we're dealing with fertility issues too
with charlotte and harry so there's
there's so much real stuff that it's
still a comedy but it's the first time
the show's like okay these are real
people let's let's put them through real
situations and a pretty good episode
about shoes in that season i believe uh
heather let's go back to you for your
rebuttal round why is season three maybe
a little better than season six
well i always hate to end things first
of all so
you know like i have my own ideas as
like a true fan of like how things
should have ended who carrie should have
been
with you know how things go so i hate
like i can i honestly can never say that
like the last season of any show is my
my favorite because it's just too sad i
get too invested as roxy said but i i
just loved also because for the first
time and i didn't mention carrie but
i'll mention her now for the first time
um in season three we saw her not
chasing mr big because right in the
first episode we saw that and all
through season two but he was
unavailable yes she was still thinking
about him obviously as women do um but
she wasn't chasing him and so she would
open herself up to more experiences as
well and yes like i'm so happy we got to
these endpoints not gonna argue with
roxy there was some of the best
television right now i just told you
season six had my best moment um but you
know to get to these to get to these
nice end points we have to see them grow
and struggle and nothing ended well in
in season three um i mean miranda's with
steve so that's nice um uh samantha she
hadn't quite figured out that she wanted
to be in a monogamous relationship at
that point carrie
the disaster of season three with carrie
and her love life with the triangle with
aiden and mr big and then charlotte of
course getting married and realizing
that it's not all it's cracked up to be
and so like that is that is real life
you know the the end bow is not what
we're all dealing with right now um in
our lives we are all just struggling
through it together and so season three
i like to see them struggle because i
know the end is coming but like you
don't know that in your own life
we don't get the bow at the end of the
episode so i like to see the more real
the realities of like going through a
really hard time
i'm gonna say that now if i'm having a
tough week and my friends are like hey
mark what's wrong i'm gonna be like man
i'm just going through season three
right now man
see you there you go the season three of
my wife man um all right roxy you're a
rebuttal too why because like it heather
does make a good point it's hard for tv
shows to stick the landing sometimes why
did season six do it so brilliantly well
season six sticks the landing because
everybody knows that everybody says
there shouldn't have been movies or
another show because season six rounded
it up so well so the fact that people
were like this is how it should have
ended and it ended this way it means
that they did the right thing and they
did right by their characters but i just
want to talk about season three for a
second because
when when people
talk about sex in the city and they say
something along the lines of i hate
carrie i hate carrie this is what
they're talking about season three carry
is what they are talking about this is
the season where our protagonist becomes
the antagonist this is somebody who we
are watching with a great guy aiden he's
the guy that you all want to be with
you're looking at aiden and you're like
this is the guy that you hope your
friend marries and she's like you know
what i should do i should light him on
fire and not pee on him while he's on
fire and instead i should go back to my
ex and start sleeping with him and have
an affair because i don't care about
anybody but myself i'm carrie bradshaw
and to have a show that is not seinfeld
that is not it's always sunny in
philadelphia where you're allowed to
hate your characters to have a show for
an entire season where for you you
cannot stand the lead character it
became
unbearable to watch her you wanted her
off her own show
okay for the record before we get to
final arguments i will say as somebody
who's done multiple ride-alongs with
real firefighters p is highly overrated
in terms of actually combating flames so
i just want to put that out there don't
ask how i know i just know okay
final argument time for what has become
the best debate of the show so far
season three for heather your final
statement i can't believe you're hating
on carrie i mean listen truth like she
did some shady things in that season and
it was not very easy to like her but
hate is a very strong word roxy okay no
but i mean like that's the whole point
of this to me it's like life is messy we
all do things that we are ashamed about
we all do things that our friends look
at us and are like you are making a
terrible decision you may have just
effed up your life you have broken up i
mean i'm not not personally speaking
about you you broke up a marriage you're
dealing with all these things like
that's just that's just life and i just
i like the idea that we i mean i know
that television is an escape but i also
like the idea of like they can get
through it so i can get through whatever
nonsense whatever fire i'm going through
i want to know that the at the end of
the day like my friends will still be
there there for me too and maybe you
don't like me during this season but
we're going to get the season six as i
hit my microphone
we're gonna get there we're gonna get to
season six okay stick with me
and we did get there and roxy loved it
so roxy season six wrapped up sex in the
city now you get to wrap up your
argument for said season it's just
incredible that a show like this that
had 500 men come and go and had so many
different storylines
wrapped up so beautifully the it's not
just the final season it's not just the
final episode it's the final season that
they were like we have to do right by
our fans where should charlotte end up
we what do we want for her we want her
to be happy we want her finally found
her man after we went through that
disaster of a trey storyline in season
three where she ended up with a a
nightmare person although the thing we
hated about him is that he had e.d which
by the way does not hold up today like
how is that going to be what we're mad
at him about there was a lot of other
things but we finally find her person
and that's what we wanted for her we we
have that for all the women and it is
hopeful without feeling like super sappy
and saturated and it wraps it up so well
that people wanted it to just stay there
because they did a whole season 20
episodes building two here you go you're
welcome fans
man this was fun to listen to so
this does appeal to not just my sex and
the city fandom which i do possess some
of it also hits me right in the star
wars feels because i feel like we're
debating empire strikes back versus
return of the jedi here because in
season three heather's absolutely right
we see carrie not necessarily as the
antagonist that roxy might make her out
to be how we might have felt at the time
but you're revealing layers to this
character and you get deeper into the
mythology if you will she becomes a
fully fleshed out person who is capable
of making erroneous decisions even if
she is the star of the show and then you
have roxy's return of the jedi here
which is taking so many of these
storylines it's like going back behind
one of those old fat back tvs and having
to untangle all the chords and making
sure that it all makes sense at the end
of the day and so while i
am so torn between both of these
arguments i do feel like throughout the
history we intimated as much earlier
television usually doesn't stick the
landing as well as it does with season
six and i think that that is the highest
hurdle to hit if you are a beloved
television series the more loved you are
the harder it seems to have a quality
final hurrah and i think sex and the
city did that and roxy illuminated us to
that so as much as i love empire strikes
back i do prefer ewoks so i think i'm
going with roxy streier's argument for
season six in round number three and it
is now two to one in favor of roxy
striyer this is just how quickly things
can get heated and can get changed and
switched around on this show now we move
to round number four but there is a
caveat because there are there are
technically two rounds left i want to
see if we can get to both rounds and so
for round number four i want to just
speed it up a little bit so we're going
to shed the rebuttal we're going to shed
the closing argument we're simply going
to do a minute each and then if i'm nice
on what y'all each have a final argument
real quick but we're going to a
speed-ish round for round number four
and that round is of course you knew it
was coming y'all who is carrie's best
boyfriend
and we're going to start with roxy stry
roxy one minute on the clock
okay he's not the best man he's not the
best man i'll i'll never say that he is
he is carrie's best boyfriend and that
is big we know he's carrie's best
boyfriend because every other man she's
with she leaves her cheats on to be with
big and we also know it because we got
then two movies and another tv series
and she ended up with big so that who
you end up with the person that you
deserve to be with is the person that
you choose every single day no matter
how great all the other guys are around
you big keeps her on her toes that's
important to her why is it important to
her i'm not quite sure but we see that
it is we see that she loves that he's
mysterious that she loves these big
grand romantic gestures everyone has
different love languages she knows hers
her love language has a name his name is
big she doesn't care that he can't
commit when he can't commit she doesn't
care that he moves to paris she cares
that he is rich he will give her the
lifestyle that he she needs and she
cares that that is the person that for
some reason she is drawn to the most and
wants to be her partner the best
boyfriend for carrie is the one that she
picks from day one of the show to the
last moment of the of the most recent
episode of and just like that it's big
if you enjoy roxy's work you can catch
her at the hilton ballroom b giving a
motivational speech that was stirring
i'm ready to run through a brick wall
let's go to heather so heather i have a
feeling i know who your answer is going
to be roxy took big who in your opinion
is the best carrie boyfriend it's going
to be hard for me to not just go ahead
and start with the rebuttal because i do
not think that big
yeah i agree he wasn't a good man but he
also was a terrible terrible boyfriend
from from the very first episode all the
way yeah he went and get her from paris
whatever but like it took six years no
aiden from day one was the nicest pushed
her to be like i said that better person
again maybe it'd be because he just got
introduced to us in season three maybe
i'm a little bit partial here but this
was her growing moment and she needed to
get out of you know the the the crazy
guys i love that she would like stuck
with another guy that wasn't big that
she actually like learned what it was
like to be treated correctly uh i'm
sorry the bathroom scene where he just
makes this gorgeous uh candlelit uh
bathtub for her oh my gosh yeah yes give
me the shoes give me the rich lifestyle
but also that counts too i'm sorry
riches fade away but someone that sweet
and that nice and he always always
always put her needs first there was
never a wandering eye incident from him
there was never a oh sorry baby i can't
i gotta go to work today incident which
we saw for six years with big so he was
the m i know not the right guy for her
that's fine but i believe this category
was best boyfriend and he was the best
boyfriend he treated her so much better
than everyone else on this entire series
it's a good thing carrie's not a touring
comedian because uh i don't know that
you could ever trust big at home if
you're going to do the funny bone in
cincinnati
you got to bring the guy with you you
just can't trust him now i will say that
big again start to finish was seemingly
the perfect fit for carrie if you're
talking about the best boyfriend i
remember seeing aiden and being like oh
that's me and not that i'm that handy
around the house i can fix a few things
i do enjoy a kfc bucket of chicken as a
result
that might be my birthday meal as a
matter of fact
i feel like
i'm going to go with the better human
here and i think that sometimes in a
partner we look for somebody who isn't
necessarily the best fit for us right
now but somebody who elevates us to a
higher plane i don't know that aidan
always did that with carrie but i think
that i believe in that willpower enough
to give the win to aiden and us to
heather here in round four that also
happens to set us up for a tiebreaker
round of epic proportions so it is two
to two we got cosmos we got f and
miranda hats this is everything that you
want in a sex in the city binge battle
and now it all comes down to the final
round it's going to be a speed round
again but i will give you all a final
argument in there as well because the
question is simply
is and just like that
good is it worth
revisiting so
we might have to do this a little
differently because roxy i know you've
seen it heather have you seen and just
like that
well no and that sets me up for my
answer it's not worth watching
then you know what i'll let you have the
four first you can you can say why you
as a huge fan of sex in the city have
not seen and just like that
i mean i i agree with everything roxy
said about the sixth season and what you
said too it is so so so difficult for
television to get series right
when they end and especially some as
beloved as sex in the city it is hard
and we have a much longer list of all
the things that went wrong rather than
this like golden standard of the things
that went right and sex in the city
falls in that category i'm happy with
that i really am it's fine with me to
just leave it that way i don't i didn't
feel like i needed any more and i saw
the movies and they were fine they were
i i kind of had them as their own little
entities but i didn't need a
continuation of the story i did feel i
really did even though it pains me to
agree with roxy
i i did feel that it just had a great
bow and and reboots are really hard for
hollywood to get right uh my favorite
show of all time is how i met your
mother and i immediately flocked through
how i met your father because why not
and i immediately regretted it i don't
need to mess with a good thing i'm
probably going to watch it i just didn't
rush to go do it because i just loved
the series so much as a standalone
entity hollywood got it right don't mess
with a good thing
great references to both the cincinnati
bengals and minnesota vikings woes of
the past in how i met your mother so
roxy you have a tall order here but if
you pull it off you might win the whole
binge battle can you convince me because
i haven't seen it either
and heather why we need to watch and
just like that
did we need to make this show absolutely
not
now that they made it
it's awesome and i'm not kidding you
like i cannot get over how good this
show is and i keep texting my friends
who haven't watched it to say you have
to watch this show what they have done
is so wild because they made our
characters who used to be progressive
when they were 30 they made them the
non-progressive ones of this show they
don't know what's up with society
anymore and so they're starting to try
to figure out how do we live in a world
where we are on podcasts with people who
are non-binary and we keep messing up
their pronouns how do we live in a world
where my professor is black with braids
and i commented on her braids because
i'm miranda and i didn't know any better
because i am not that progressive it is
it's incredible that they decided our
characters are not precious enough to us
that we're going to make them look like
saints we're going to put them in real
situations and show that while talking
about masturbating when they were 30 was
on the cutting edge now you're 50 and
now you're behind you have to constantly
keep up the way that this show handles
samantha not being there is the best
they could possibly do would it be
better if she was there of course but
she's not and it's still sex in the city
so what they do is they decide all right
we're gonna break up a bunch of
relationships because this is sex and
the city and now we're watching what we
were watching before with 30 year old
women having sex in the city we're
watching 50 year old women having sex in
the city it's
really really good and i'm not just
saying that to win this argument i am
telling you this show is good like
i was shocked i was gonna give it one
episode and then i'm in it's very good
heather i'm gonna give you a final
argument but you can also just simply
say if roxy won you over or not
well the the part i mean because i
haven't seen it so i didn't know that
they all broke up
what
you just told me that you loved all of
the great like the way that everything
just tied together and now we're just
gonna like throw a wrench at it what no
i don't want to see that i want to live
in my fantasy world whereby goes and
gets her from the mean guy who slapped
her in paris and whisks her back to be
with her true soul mates and she can and
they can all live out their lives in
beautiful harmony don't tell me that
everything gets bad again
all right roxy your final argument for
why we need to see and just like that
okay so they didn't all break up and i
don't think there's a spoiler because it
made me national national news but
for the first episode we know that big
is no longer in the picture so the the
way that now and that happens in life
you think you finally think you found
your man you've gone through everything
and guess what they die
because things happen in life so what do
you do you have to keep living and you
have to learn how to have sex again and
and lean on your friends your actual
soulmates remember we learned that
earlier best moment of the show
the way that they have decided uh also
just calling a space spade this was the
whitest show of all time we all know
that and then it was like this this show
was like okay
now we're not gonna just do that thing
where we throw one person of color in
there and say now we're not a white show
we are going to explore people of all
different backgrounds all different
races and we're going to show you guys
that sex in the city is not exclusive to
white people you not it's not only
people having sex in the city are white
spoiler alert like
insane and they're they're writing some
of their wrongs even though i love that
original show we know what happened in
the 90s and the 2000s
they didn't do they didn't do right by
anybody who wasn't white so it's
correcting a lot of mistakes it made and
it's doing it in a really powerful funny
way
all right uh compelling arguments all
around not just in this round but
throughout the entire episode of binge
battle it's been so much fun now
they had the hard work up until this
point kids because now it's my job to
have to come up with somebody who won
this and i think what it comes down to
for me is like look i referenced star
wars before i think it was troublesome
for a lot of people and they're a little
apprehensive to dip their toes back in
those waters and see what happened to
our heroes because return of the jedi
ended on such a high note we won and now
oh no we have to live the rest of our
life but as somebody who has not seen
and just like that yet i think roxy did
sway me for a couple different reasons
not the least of which is that my mom is
single and she is currently
you know seeing folks and i think that
that's an important thing to see on tv
is that you don't have to be this young
attractive 20-something to be in a big
city and that's your time to date and
figure out who you're gonna be with that
can go on later on in life but i also
feel like
heather's probably gonna watch this too
now because it was a good argument for
roxy i mean what i can't even hide it
i'm gonna watch it thank you
i'm going to i will i was concerned
about samantha not being there but then
i remembered that i'm a huge van halen
fan and i saw van halen in 2015.
original bass player michael anthony
wasn't there and it would have been nice
to see him but i still got to see van
halen and so
again by the slimmest of margins both
incredible passionate arguments
throughout this show
i'm giving the w today
to the person who has a sex in the his
city hat that she hates roxy streamer
gets the win but heather's got a great
cosmo to enjoy as a consolation roxy
roxy this is this one's for you oh
cheers baby
charlotte and never being called a
miranda ever again
seriously thank you i'll drink to that
i will bite my tongue then and i will
say we have two samantha's on the show
first of all oh i wouldn't go that far
you samantha lovers two samantha fans
here on the show starting with our
winning samantha fan roxy stryer roxy
quickly where can all the kids out there
find you what are you working on where
can they follow you on the social medias
everywhere at roxy stream and also the
world girls which you can find at the
world girls we give everything a whirl
and it's a lot of fun so if samantha is
your favorite character i bet she would
love our show too she gives things a
whirl all the time
and heather it's been such a delight
having you make your debut here on binge
battle where can everybody find you out
there on the social media platforms this
was so so so so so much fun and i hope
you invite me back so i can
maybe do another rebattle with roxy here
i feel like i got some stronger
arguments in me uh you can find me all
over at heather g tv it's the same on
all the platforms i'm making it real
easy for y'all
we have a lot of fun binge battle
episodes coming up and i'd love to have
both you all back we're going to a
galaxy far far away soon we're sticking
with the more current hbo show sooner
rather than later so there's a whole lot
of fun here at rotten tomatoes binge
battle for the latest and greatest with
rotten tomatoes just head over to their
website it's easy rottentomatos.com you
can check out my podcast alongside jack
when coley rotten tomatoes is wrong and
for upcoming stand up dates you can go
to my website mark ellis dot live for
everybody here including christian ruble
cobb our hardworking engineer and his
sweet puppy draco i am mark ellis molly
the wonder dog is over there for heather
gardner roxy streier thanks for watching
binge battle we'll see you next
bring it time